at the start of the program a star was
born tonight
his name senator tim scott from the
great state of south carolina take a
look
our best future will not come from
washington schemes or socialist dreams
it will come from you the american
people
black hispanic white and asian
republican
and democrat brave police officers in
black neighborhoods
we are not adversaries we are
philippines
all right joining us now for reaction
also from the great state of south
carolina
senator lindsey graham now senator tim
scott's here tomorrow so
senator tim scott is he's not really
a star born tonight we both have known
for a long time
he's a star um and every time he's on my
radio show he does my radio show he'll
be on tv tomorrow night
a lot and all we do is make fun of you
good and talk about how he's really the
senior more popular senator from the
great state of south carolina
well let me tell you got a lot to work
with if you want to make fun of me
here's the deal tim scott is one of the
smartest people i've ever met
he has a genuine good heart very
principled
and what you and i know the country saw
tonight
so tim you made your state proud you
made conservatism proud
tim explained to the american people
with a smile on his face
that there's an alternative to biden's
america
joe biden scared the hell out of me
tonight he looked weak as commander in
chief
and he embraced socialism tim scott
made me feel great about being a
republican
proud to be from south carolina and
hopeful about my country
but he became public enemy number one
tonight
check out the internet and see what the
liberals are saying about
tim scott so vote timscott.com
is his website they're going to crush
this guy if they can
jamie harrison my opponent who raised
132 million dollars
is now the democratic national committee
chairman
he is going after tim in a big way
tonight
so if you want to help tim go to vote
timscott.com
and give what you can because the
enemies
of tim scott are going to do the same
tonight
we need to have tim's back like you have
my back
i remember what it was like after
cavanaugh tim
is in for a real a real challenge here
and we need to help him
well um but count me in uh because
uh he is an amazing leader you know it's
very interesting we've been
the times you've been on this program
we've been looking forward to 2022.
we're just a few seats away
republicans taking back the house and if
you want to talk about a bellwether for
2024 you've got to look at
the the senatorial map for 2022.
florida georgia north carolina new
hampshire
wisconsin ohio and arizona
something interesting was said by the
great senator
democrat uh kelly from arizona
on biden's speech what i didn't hear
tonight was a plan to address the
immediate crisis at the border
uh i'll continue holding the
administration accountable to deliver
the resources now
uh to me i don't think that that senator
kelly from arizona
would have said that if he wasn't up for
re-election in 2022 but
you know what can i say i'm cynical
well all i can say is if you watch your
show you'll learn a lot about the border
and politics in general
why did mark kelly mention the fact that
joe biden didn't talk about
solving the border crisis because joe
biden
is the crisis the root cause of our
the run on the border is not the
northern triangle countries
they're no better no worse than they
were when trump they're better i think
because of trump
the bottom line is joe biden instituted
catch and release if you come to america
you get released in the country
you never show up to your court date if
you're under 16 you stay here
word is out all over central america
that joe biden has gone back to catch
and release
and mark kelly knows unless you change
catch and release and reform asylum
it's never ending and the reason biden
never mentioned it
is because the left won't let him
mention it the root cause of
immigration chaos is joe biden
so everything now has a different
meaning than when we were used to
infrastructure means child
care infrastructure means redistribution
infrastructure is the green new deal
everything all right so you got two
trillion emergency covert relief that
was anything but emergency covert relief
and you got this new what 4 trillion
plus that they're going to spend on all
the
these other radical policies
uh i don't know i don't think you need a
degree from mit
or harvard to figure out that those
numbers don't add up
and uh joe biden said he's going to be
able to do it without creating a deficit
senator i got i got an iphone like
everybody else
has a calculator on it i can do the
simple math
and pretty much if we confiscated the
wealth of
every rich person which we're getting
pretty close to
we still wouldn't balance a budget would
we
no i mean what joe biden did tonight was
introduced the largest power grab
in american history as president
more than fdr he didn't talk about court
packing you didn't talk about ending the
legislative filibuster
he didn't talk about d.c statehood he
didn't talk about what's really
radically going on in terms of the power
grab he kind of
he even though he said during the
campaign oh you supported none of these
things
i saw a weak joe biden tonight a dull
job biden not the guy that you knew
years ago
yeah really i saw a socialist tonight i
saw a man who embraced socialism what
did he tell us
to save american families we're going to
grow the government
the bottom line is infrastructure now is
about climate change it's not about
roads and bridges
and he talked about russia and china in
terms that were really unnerving to me
do you think after listening to joe
biden tonight that anybody the kremlin
is worried
do you think the chinese have any fear
in them after hearing this speech
tonight
it was incoherent on foreign policy he
talked about leaving afghanistan
as if there's no consequence to leaving
he turned
down sound military advice this is the
same joe biden
that allowed isis to come back by
leaving iraq you just wait and see what
happens
the bottom line tonight that if i ever
hear that joe biden's a moderator again
i'm going to throw up because after
night
he embraced socialism he made barack
obama a little like ronald reagan
but here's the good news there's a
better way and tim scott embodies that
way
tim scott did not only himself proud
tonight but he did conservatism
proud and uh let's help tim scott
well uh anyway thanks great night for
south carolina i will say that thank you
senator graham
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else